[Music]
um
do you have the um
everybody
so
so
so
20 seconds
10 9 8
7 6
good afternoon earlier today attorney
general
dana nessel was joined by officials from
the department of justice
and the fbi to announce state and
federal charges against
13 members of two militia groups who
were preparing to kidnap
and possibly kill me when i put my hand
on the bible
and took the oath of office 22 months
ago i knew this job would be hard
but i'll be honest i never could have
imagined anything like this
i want to start by saying thank you to
our law enforcement
thank you to the fearless fbi agents
and thank you to the brave michigan
state police troopers
who participated in this operation
acting under the leadership
of colonel joe gasper i also want to
thank attorney general nessel
and the u.s attorneys burj and schneider
and their teams for pursuing criminal
charges that hopefully
will lead to convictions bringing these
sick and depraved men to justice
as a mom with two teenage daughters and
three step sons
my husband and i are eternally grateful
to everyone
who put themselves in harm's way to keep
our family
safe 2020 has been a hard year for all
of us
hard for our doctors and nurses and
truck drivers
grocery store workers it's been hard for
the teachers and students and parents
hard for those who have had to stay
isolated to stay
safe and it's not over yet
but here's what i know we're
michiganders
we have grit we have heart and we are
tough as hell
we made it through the great recession
we made it through auto bankruptcies
we made it through floods and polar
vortexes
but none of us has faced a challenge
like copig 19
not in our lifetimes i've said it many
times
we are not one another's enemy this
virus is our enemy
and this enemy is relentless it doesn't
care if you're a republican or a
democrat
young or old rich or poor he doesn't
care if we're tired of it
it threatens us all our lives
our families our jobs our businesses
our economy it preys on our elderly
and medically vulnerable residents and
it has exposed deep inequities in our
society
this should be a moment for national
unity
where we all pull together as americans
to meet this challenge head on with the
same might
and muscle that put a man on the moon
seeing the humanity in one another and
doing our part
to help our country get through this
instead our head of state has spent the
past
seven months denying science ignoring
his own health experts
stoking distrust fomenting anger
and giving comfort to those who spread
fear
and hatred and division just last week
the president of the united states stood
before the american people
and refused to condemn white
supremacists
and hate groups like these two michigan
militia groups
stand back and stand by he told them
stand back and stand by
hate groups heard the president's words
not as a rebuke
but as a rallying cry is a call to
action
when our leaders speak their words
matter
they carry weight when our leaders
meet with encourage or fraternize
with domestic terrorists they legitimize
their actions
and they are complicit when they stoke
and contribute to hate speech
they are complicit in 1981
president ronald reagan spoke to the
naacp's annual convention
and his comments stand in sharp contrast
to what we have seen on the national and
state level from his own beloved party
in 2020
he said a few isolated groups in the
backwater of american life
still hold perverted notions of what
america is all about
recently in some places in the nation
there's been a disturbing recurrence
of bigotry and violence then reagan sent
a direct message
to those who still adhere to senseless
racism and religious
prejudice you are the ones who are out
of step with our society he said
you are the ones who willfully violate
the meaning of the dream
that is america and this country
because of what it stands for will not
stand for your conduct
so let me say this loud and clear
hatred bigotry and violence have no
place
in the great state of michigan if you
break the law
or conspire to commit heinous acts of
violence
against anyone we will find you
we will hold you accountable and we will
bring you to justice
for the past seven months i've made
tough choices to keep our state
safe these have been gut-wrenching
decisions
no governor has ever had to make and i
get it
life has been hard for us all
when i get out of bed every morning i
think about the high school seniors like
my daughter
who missed graduation ceremonies those
michiganders have missed weddings
and funerals i think about all the moms
who are working from home
making breakfast every day logging their
kids onto their zoom class
and doing the laundry think about the
small business owners who spent a
lifetime building something great who
are now
hanging on by their fingernails just to
keep the lights on
the disruption this virus has caused to
our daily lives is immeasurable
and it has already taken the lives of
more than 210
000 americans including over 6 800
right here in michigan as painful as
these losses are
our hard work and sacrifices have saved
thousands of lives
we have one of the strongest economic
recoveries in the nation
make no mistake there will be more hard
days ahead
but i want the people of michigan to
know this as your governor
i will never stop doing everything in my
power to keep you
and your family safe you don't have to
agree with me
but i do ask one thing never forget
that we are all in this together let's
show a little kindness
and a lot more empathy let's give one
another a little grace
and let's take care of each other wear
your mask
stay six feet apart wash your hands
frequently
and look out for your neighbors we are
michiganders
i know we can get through this we will
get through this
so let's get through it together thank
you
you